[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio at San Diego Comic-Con
2023 I'm especially excited to talk to
these two right now ghosts of Ruin I am
fascinated by this whole idea how this
show was created it's something that our
audience might not know about just yet
so Mike I'll give you these duties as
the showrunner on ghost of Ruin can you
give a brief description of what this
show is about certainly
um ghost of Ruin is a why a adult
animated series and we're a bit greedy
uh bit uh dystopian we're a bit we've
got a lot of action a lot of characters
very character driven and um it's also
got a lot of horror in it because we
like horror it's one of our things so
it's it's really fun it's it takes place
in the near future in a sort of
dystopian San Francisco and we're doing
a a tournament of Ruin which will which
is going to debut the brand new fully
immersive technology called neural
reality and a hundred of the world's
best Gamers of which she's won is coming
together to compete in this epic battle
of Royale where they're gonna like just
play the game for the first time and
it's going to be something really
amazing and this Lee this young nobody
from the cubes he wins a chance to be a
part of this and he's just in way over
his head and um then they all get into
trouble because there's something else
in the game that's hunting them
something horrible something monstrous
and it's killing them one by one in
horrible ways I have so many follow that
was a great description by the way but
I'm ruining my order here a couple
things I want to follow up on I was
looking on Instagram at the player cards
You released what rank is your player
well Frank is Juggernaut that's a great
question actually am I just
non-observant what bank is Juggernaut
your your character's card wasn't up
there so yeah
we'll have to we'll have to send it to
you after the fact because okay I think
I think she was ranked five okay but
there's actually gen is not the highest
ranked player but she's got the most
sort of like um attitude I've got
questions about that attitude another
word you brought up from the cubes what
does that mean specifically in this near
future as in Unfortunately today I guess
there's there's a real this
disparagement between you know them
those that have and those that have not
and I think that Lee is from the sort of
the poor part of town and and there's
very few people have all the money and
pretty much everyone else
that sounds familiar doesn't it yeah I
imagine
we see more and more cautionary tales
coming to life nowadays well deserving
your first acting experience right uh
voice acting voice acting is this
something you sought out or were you
approached with this opportunity I mean
a little bit of both I'm gonna be honest
because I have my like American agency
UTA and through them I was given the
chance to audition for this incredible
project but I'm someone that's always
had a love for animation and voice
acting in general is something I really
wanted to try for just years so I'm just
I'm really stoked to be part of this
many follow-up questions because now I
have to know you're a fan of Animation
do you have a single favorite series or
movie
um if I'm gonna be completely honest I'm
a huge anime fan specifically so Death
Note is my one and true love one and
only true love
excellent choice right there thank you
um so you get the opportunity to
audition for this when you're even
prepping for your audition what is your
biggest burning question that you need
to ask the people you're auditioning for
to kind of like wrap your head around
what this even is uh honestly it's just
kind of like what are you looking for in
this character you know because once I
have like a vague idea of like okay this
is the image we have for her this is
kind of about like she faces things with
her attitude it's like okay let me try
to bring that to life okay so yeah we're
coming back to that attitude okay you
have a lot of experience working in
animation but again I keep hinting at
the fact that this is a very different
show in terms of the way it was created
can you tell me something about your
approach to the work that has stayed the
same from your past animation experience
to this but then also name something
about this process that is entirely
different
perhaps only
um for me all good storytelling is about
character so it's always character
character character and every show I've
ever worked on even though there'll be
heavy plot lines throughout the
animation or even it's a comedy it's all
about the character and so that's never
changed and that's what this show is all
about for me it's like yeah there's this
dystopian future and it's the the
horrible monsters killing people in this
game but really at the end of the day
it's about these characters and how they
come together and they're a found family
and uh juggernauts got an older he's
like a brother but he's not a brother
named castle and they're like
Inseparable these two you know they grew
up together and he's always look out for
and they look out for each other and so
it's about those relationships and that
that's always stayed true through
everything I've ever tried to do and how
that's something that's completely
different given the fan interaction that
was involved in actually creating what
we're going to see in the end product
that's what's so brilliant I love it
because I've been doing this a long time
probably far longer than any adult
should be doing animation but luckily
I'm very immature sure in my head so it
works out
the community involvement is so
brilliant it's like so many shows I've
worked on we've been so separated from
the fans just by time alone but also
when you're working in on Bigger
Productions or you're working sort of in
in a space you don't interact with fans
you're very isolated but here we got to
actually work with fans work with
Community early on and I would I would
have them vote on things I would have
them vote on like props and models like
what what do you think juggernauts boots
should look like and we would give them
different options and they would and
they'd all vote and then we we had um we
had different votes on uh on dialogue
like we'd have we had Alexa read like
four different versions of one line and
and they all ever they got to vote on
which one they liked the best and not
winning the show so it's just been this
great interaction like from the very
beginning the script process even we
were sort of interacting with the fans
that is the coolest thing ever I I do
have a question about where you draw the
line in terms of fan inter interaction
though in picking things so that when
they see the finished product everything
isn't spoiled for them and it's still a
surprise that was actually a real
consideration because we were worried
we'd give away too much so even when we
had to pick dialogue lines it was like
there were certain lines I wanted to to
give the fans but I was like no that
gives away too much information that
might spoil something for them so we had
to really think about what was sort of
put in front of them so it wouldn't
spoil the uh the whole thing I like that
you get the best of both worlds there so
going back to Juggernaut now so I don't
ask you like who is jug or not at the
beginning of the show what do you think
the character's greatest strength is but
then I also want to know her greatest
weakness the thing that will do her in
in this tournament and what they need to
do to survive I mean with my knowledge
of the plot thus far I would like to say
probably her advantage and weakness
might be the same thing
which is just like her like spark this
like spontaneity she has I guess you
know she's like if I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna do it now hold me
back I'm gonna do I'm gonna commit to
the bit but at the same time that could
also be kind of detrimental in many ways
okay so okay that is that's like the
core of an interesting character where
their greatest strength is also their
greatest weakness so given how you just
described her is there the opportunity
to kind of play on the spot because like
you have your own interpretation of the
role you have what the fans are voting
on for you to say what about just like
being spontaneous on the spot in the
sound booth I mean fortunately I was
actually given the opportunity to kind
of just say whatever a few times when we
recording like hey just you know say
feel like during this kind of scenario
How would how would Juggernaut react I
just fed some few lines and like you
know what we'll take it so when you're
playing like that can you maybe give me
an example of something you did that
felt so out of left field that made you
think they're never gonna actually use
this but now we might be able to see it
in the Final Cut of the show the real
question is what's camera friendly
I say on Collide or anything's camera
friendly
I like curse words very many curses
we say the f word we say everything all
right all right uh f-bombs and when I
was looking at some of the early
obviously
like blood caught my eye and the cree
the creatures who maybe give me like a
little I love horror I'll watch and read
and I like all forms of Storytelling all
genres horror is my number one so when I
see stuff like that especially in
animation which I feel like should be
embraced more baby it gets me very
excited so how far do you push it with
the blood gore and horror
uh you don't want to be gratuitous you
wanted to kind of fit the storytelling
and and but also you want to push it
because you want to give people an
experience that maybe they haven't had
yet like when you're mixing this sort of
gaming with horror and animation all
together you want to sort of give them
something that's going to surprise them
and so that's sort of my my instinct is
to sort of create those moments of blood
and gore that aren't just gratuitous and
just for the heck of it there's like
there's a real purpose behind it but
also it's it's scary and it's shocking
and and it gets your adrenaline going
that's the best kind you sign me up for
all that so you brought up the the
neural reality idea which is basically
like a step ahead of virtual reality and
what we have and what we're actively
using often right now but when it comes
to neural reality do you see like the
starting point of that in our real world
like is it it is inevitable right yeah
we our story takes place in 2065 like
what 40 years from now but I mean in in
all honesty who knows it might be sooner
you know because the way the world is
going and the way that that virtual
reality is is evolving and newer reality
is on the horizon I'd say it's really
coming fast and so and also our sense of
neurality is that you're I mean virtual
reality is enough to almost make me lost
in in with my brain and like am I really
experiencing this but when you actually
get to neuro reality your brain won't be
able to tell the difference so all of
our perceptions that we're just looking
around here and we're talking we're
talking to each other
our brain won't be able to tell the
difference if we're in newer reality if
we're actually experiencing this or not
experiencing it and that's that's what
we're dealing with well that's what
sparked the whole idea was the fact that
this young guy gets his brain shattered
in new reality and he's got PTSD from it
and it's like are we going to suffer
like trauma in when we play these games
if it's so real to our brains how's our
brain going to know the difference so
functions as a cautionary tale a little
bit okay okay I think we need more of
those in the world
um to highlight some of the other
characters now here's another Juggernaut
question for you so you brought up
Castle so I have a feeling that
character might be the answer to one
part of this but of all the players in
the game who does she respect the most
and who does she respect the lead oh man
okay again just based off of my
knowledge of the plot thus far and what
I've recorded she definitely holds
Castle very near and dear to her like I
mean again like Mike had said they're
Inseparable basically like siblings
though they're not related by blood
um but the thing is I feel like with
prism there's this level of I do respect
you but at the same time I kind of hate
your ass like you know it's kind of like
not exactly sibling rivalry because they
don't have that kind of Sisterhood going
on but it's just very there's a bit of
animosity there but mixed in with the
okay I'll listen to you but if you
listen to me you know that kind of give
and take Rosario Dawson's character
right yeah yeah I mean your voice cast
here is exceptional of all of the roles
in the show which voice Factor was the
easiest to cast where like the perfect
person just magically emerge and fit the
role and then which character was the
most difficult to find the perfect fit
for well I mean and this is going to
sound like I'm saying it because she's
sitting right next to me but Alexa was
like a godsend for us in terms of
Juggernaut because
um she was already Juggernaut when we
did the auditions and we're like oh my
gosh she's perfect for this like we I
think we knew we wanted her like right
away but we have to go through the
process of doing callbacks and double
checking to make sure you're not we're
just not imagining it you know and so
she was the character from the beginning
and and she brings so much life to the
character so that was the easiest one I
think definitely you even see it in that
real like you're you only see you I
think deliver maybe one or two words I'm
like oh like this just feels right and I
I barely know anything about the show
thus far thank you exactly exactly the
hardest one I and it's a it's a it's a
character named Dr Brennan and he's he's
this very uh very academic kind of Pro
and he's also very cold and and
calculated and he's got this kind of a
voice for me that was really hard to
find because he has to be also human but
underneath it but he has to be also very
kind of like scientific but he's also
one of our I don't want to go spoiler
away but he's got some he's got some
things going on that we're gonna find
out later aren't so great and um uh it
was a hard voice but
um John Bentley came in and did it and
he's just a pro and and and we worked
for a little bit on it and he found just
the right voice that was in my ear and I
was like oh that's it that's it and so
that one took more time to find only
because the character himself is is is
you don't want a cliche you want to find
something that has layers to it and so
that was the hardest character where are
you all in the production of the show we
are yeah are physically in production on
the first four episodes we're in
animation on the first four we've we've
already gotten most of the other scripts
written for the second four actually
those are all written
um and so we're pretty much in
production on on the show and the first
one is due out in um
well right around yeah
probably early September mid-september
okay I'm gonna gonna drop it's very it's
very exciting all four episodes should
drop by October 15th okay and where
where can people watch it when the time
comes we are having a really kind of a
cool moment with Gala film
um they're they're gonna they're our
parent company and they're just they've
just been beautiful with us and um
they've got a special sort of debut on
their their web 3 space on the gala film
space okay I'm I am curious about web3
there was a quote that I read somewhere
where it was like that technology is
going to continue to change the industry
as we move forward so can you maybe give
an example of like a way that people can
pinpoint it being used on ghost of Ruin
now and maybe something that you know
you haven't even tapped into that could
change the game in the future on future
Seasons maybe absolutely I think
um there's so many ways that web3's been
sort of an amazing Brave New World I
think in terms of in terms of especially
this in terms of community in terms of
people coming together from different
areas all over the world and coming
together and making a show like this and
that's what's so exciting to me it's
like we actually created a show in the
web 3 space for the web three space with
the fans with the community themselves
and I think that's a that's a game
changer right there and I think that's
only going to get more that's to me the
beauty of web3 is that it's the people
it's the community it's this everyone
coming together and making something or
making a group of people that all want
to hang out together you know it's just
it's so cool yeah I mean that's that's
why I love TV and film that's why I love
Comic-Con so much it's like we're
literally right smack in the middle
right now I love it I love it so for
voice acting now what is something again
I know you're not finished with uh the
performance work on this particular
season but what is something you've
accomplished thus far that you're really
proud of but then also what is like a
new skill you've tapped into that you're
eager to use with what recording lies
ahead for you in the future fantastic
question
um let's see I don't know I think
overall just the fact that this is the
first professional voice acting gig I've
had let alone to be casted by somebody
like Mike Ryan I'm like damn this is
never thought I'd be doing this but here
I am thank god
um like skill set wise I think just
learning how to read in a booth that's
the thing because again with like
auditions it's just like you know you
record yourself you send it in but like
actually getting feedback in real time
learning how to adjust and tweak the way
you say things play better line delivery
it's definitely something that was a
really good uh I guess skill set that
was learned during the recording process
this is gonna get awkward but one of the
things that fascinates me most about uh
voice performances is when people like
it's hard enough to delivering the lines
but when people have to do efforts
efforts of of the bunch what effort
comes most naturally to you but then
what is like the everyday sound a human
being makes that's most difficult for
you to replicate exactly that's a great
question because I mean ghosts everyone
there is fighting happening I'm I don't
normally make fighting noises on The
Daily like that's not something I do uh
so I guess finding what sounds natural
especially there's a difference between
giving an attack versus receiving one
so it's like you know I guess finding
the differentiation between those two
and seeing okay this sounds like it
could happen if I got hit in the head
with a crowbar like you know I guess
those little nuances make all the
difference they do you have good
leadership guiding you through this
though I have to let you go because you
have a lot of celebrating to do but huge
congratulations on what you've
accomplished thus far I'm fascinated by
this whole idea I cannot wait to see the
finished product thank you so much thank
you so much